>> The Library of Congress
in Washington DC.
>> Mary-Jane Deeb: Welcome
to Library of Congress.
I am Mary-Jane Deeb, Chief of the
African and Middle Eastern Division
and I wish you all a happy Nowruz.
We are celebrating today Nowruz
with a special cultural program
on Azerbaijani culture and food, and
I just want to say that every year,
the African and Middle Eastern
division, which is responsible
for the collections and for
serving those collections
from 78 different countries
is here and collects materials
from Azerbaijan that
it serves, as well.
Now why we celebrate Nowruz,
it is because it is a secular
facility sacred to the Zoroastrians,
but in fact, celebrated not
only in Iran, the Persian world,
the Persian speaking world, but
also throughout central Asia
from Kazakhstan, Kyrgyzstan,
Uzbekistan,
and certainly in Azerbaijan.
It is also celebrated in India,
and in some of the people in Iraq
and Turkey, in Turkmenistan,
and many other places.
And every year, we
do something special.
So this is a very special
event today 2016, for example,
we celebrated it at the White House.
We were invited by Mrs.
Obama, and we had a display
and a special Nowruz lunch
at the White House in 2015.
We had a special presentation
by Dr. Saeed Hussein Nasser,
and many of you know him
at George Washington.
In 2014, we opened a big exhibit
on 1000 years of the Persian book.
A year earlier, we had a
film on the Shah Hanami.
So year after year, we have unique
programs that celebrate new year,
celebrate the beginning of spring.
I know it's a not very
auspicious the snow outside,
but we do what we can to
bring spring to everyone
and to bring spring through
Nowruz, through the programs,
through the food, through
the culture, which is so rich
and so wonderful, and you
hear much more about it today.
We are delighted to be cosponsoring
this event today with the embassy
of Azerbaijan, and the embassy
has been absolutely wonderful,
has a fantastic team.
We have a young lady, Fadoon
[assumed spelling] here,
who has been a dynamo
putting this together
in a very short period of time.
So I want to thank the
embassy of Azerbaijan
for also making possible this
wonderful menu and event today.
We have with us, and
we are honored to have
with us today the ambassador
from Azerbaijan.
His Excellency, Elin Suleymanov, was
appointed ambassador of the Republic
of Azerbaijan to the United
States in October 2011.
Prior to that, for over five years,
Mr. Suleymanov had been the nation's
first consul general to Los Angeles
and the Western states leading team,
which established Azerbaijani
diplomatic presence
on the western coast.
He's a graduate of the Fletcher
School of Law and Diplomacy
in Medford, Massachusetts,
and holds a graduate degree
from the political
geography department
of Moscow State University in Russia
and from the University
of Toledo, Ohio.
Mr. Suleymanov, His Excellency,
Ambassador Suleymanov,
has authored numerous articles
and is a frequent presenter
at academic events.
He is fluent in several languages,
and now we'll ask them to be fluent
in English and welcome
you all, of thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Elin Suleymanov:
Thank you, Ms. Deeb.
This a great honor to be here.
My English is heavily accented.
So I'm not sure how
fluent I'm going to be,
but I will ask you to bear with me.
The happy thing, it's
going be very short.
So, Ms. Deeb, thank you so
much for partnering with us.
It's a great honor to be
speaking in this marvelous hall.
We all know about Library of
Congress from her childhood,
from different things, but now,
we're finally presenting here
in a partnership with
Library of Congress.
Thank you so much, Ms. Deeb.
Thank you to the division.
Thank you to the team.
Thank you, Ms. Weeks,
for being with us.
Thank you.
I actually have a book itself
to present you, but we'll do,
but I will also ask
Feride later to sign it.
So you'll have it actually --
we could have pre-signed it,
we thought it would be better if
she signed it in your presence.
>> Mary-Jane Deeb: Absolutely.
>> Elin Suleymanov: So Ms.
Deeb, thank you very much.
This is the book itself.
>> Mary-Jane Deeb: Thank you.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
>> Elin Suleymanov: So thank
you for your partnership.
If Feride could sign it.
>> Mary-Jane Deeb: That's wonderful.
Thank you.
>> Elin Suleymanov: And
while the ladies do that,
let me say a couple of words.
First of all, we are
very proud to partner
with Feride Buyuran on this book.
It was a joint project, in
which we didn't do anything.
She did all the work.
But we are very grateful.
This is the first book of its kind.
She will tell you more about this.
It's not surprising that this book
actually was written in California.
Because when you look outside the
nature and the weather of Azerbaijan
and the fruit in the meat
at all this is probably more
like California than
elsewhere anywhere else.
So, Ms. Buyuran, I'm not surprised
that you were inspired to do
that in the [inaudible]
of Los Angeles.
>> Feride Buyuran: That's true.
>> Elin Suleymanov:
Rather than elsewhere,
but we could have called this
conversation a taste of Nowruz.
As Ms. Deeb pointed out, is very
important to realize that today,
we are in the second day
of the last week of Nowruz.
I know it sounds strange for
people who don't follow this,
but we're very religious about this.
Very, very, very committed.
So happens is every Tuesday
before the actual Nowruz,
which a solar equinox, which is
the real beginning of spring,
we dedicate ourselves to eating
a lot of fattening food, sugar,
carbohydrates, and jumping over
various burning [inaudible].
Mostly fire.
It's good for you, because
it clears your soul.
Yesterday, we did that as well,
because that's a celebration
of the beginning of spring.
Don't be fooled by the cold weather.
Actually, the sun will be soon,
I think it's on Monday, right?
The night from Sunday and
Monday, it will be solar equinox.
The spring begins, and
no more cold weather.
I promise you.
That's been true for centuries.
That's been true for thousands
of years, but the celebration
of Nowruz is not possible
without the food,
because that's very much the
heart of the Nowruz celebration.
You jump, you eat,
you cleanse your soul,
and you get minimal
carbohydrates back.
So Ms. Buyuran will
be talking about this.
But what Ms. Deeb also
said is very important.
I think, in addition to the Nowruz,
at the beginning of the celebration
of the actual equinox, Nowruz
is a celebration of unity.
It's the unity of Iranian
culture, Azerbaijani culture,
culture of people of
Central Asia, the Caucuses.
So much, and throughout, and in
fact in places like the Middle East,
Iraq, and Russia, Turkestan,
and Uzbekistan.
Everybody has their own
specificity of these things.
I believe that we really
have the best [inaudible].
People believe they have
the best [inaudible].
People boil the best eggs
and keep the eggs together.
Everybody has a different thing,
but what it does, it unites people
in many ways, and it's
a fascinating field.
When you go to different places
quite far from each other, actually,
in terms of distance, and
people celebrate together.
They celebrate in a way which
is so familiar for each of us.
So I think that's, in a way, a
great opportunity for us to think
about this as a unifying force.
Especially during this
week a celebration.
Now there's something
that is also special
about this book, and
you've noticed it.
Not only the celebration bringing
us all together, the food.
If you look at the specificity of
food, it's actually very common
to so many of our neighbors,
so many of our friends,
some many of our partners.
In a way, when we say Azerbaijani
food has also been developed
under different influences.
It has influenced others.
So in a way, the unification of
food is also a very good thing.
And in addition to the
talk by Ms. Buyuran,
I also hope that we can have some
of that here, because they told me
that they will serve some food.
So I look forward to listening,
and also eating, as well.
So thank you very much and good
luck with your presentation.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Joan Weeks: [Non-English Spoken].
So --
[ Applause ]
For the others, that is welcome,
and on behalf of my colleagues,
and in particular Dr. Mary-Jane
Deeb, Chief of the African
and Middle Eastern Division,
I'd like to extend a very
warm welcome to everyone.
I'm Joan Weeks, head of the Near
East section, who's the sponsor
of today's program, along with the
embassy, and we're very pleased
to present this program
on Pomegranates
and Saffron a Culinary
Journey to Azerbaijan,
but before we start our
program, and very quickly,
before we introduce our
speaker, I'm just going
to give you a little brief
overview of where you are.
This is a custodial division, and
we have three sections that build
and serve collections
from all around the world.
We cover 78 countries and
more than two dozen languages.
The Africa section covers all
of the sub-Saharan Africa.
Hebraic section covers
Hebraic and Hebraic worldwide,
and our Near-East section
covers all of the Arab countries
in North Africa, Turkic
Central Asia, Iran, Afghanistan,
and the Muslims of Western China.
So you see it's quite extensive,
and we hope that at some
point you'll come back
into our reading room and use the
collections for your research.
I'd also like to invite
you to try out our blog,
where our specialists right
special events and stories
about our collections, and like
us on Facebook, and that way,
you'll find out about
future events, and now,
I also just like to just let you
know that if you ask a question
at the end, you are implicitly
agreeing to be used on the video
that will be uploaded
on our website.
So now I'd like to introduce
our speaker, Feride Buyuran,
who dreamed about creating her own
cook book and finally published it
after seven years of hard work
and obsession/determination.
She was born and raised
in Baku, Azerbaijan,
and moved to the United
States at the age of 24.
Feride holds a BA and MA degree
in English and literature
from the University of
Languages in Baku and an MBA
from California State
University at Long Beach.
She is the writer behind
the blog AZ-Cookbook.com
where she shares recipes and
stories from her native Azerbaijan
and her book, Pomegranates and
Saffron, a Culinary Journey
to Azerbaijan, has won
five prestigious awards.
So without further ado, let's
welcome Feride to the podium.
[ Applause ]
>> Feride Buyuran:
Thank you, Mrs. Weeks.
Thank you, Mrs. Deeb.
Thank you, Mr. Ambassador.
You've been very supportive of
my work since the early days
when I started writing the book.
Thank you for this opportunity to
be here in the Library of Congress.
Coming from LA, this is a
really big thing for me.
So I am very honored to speak
about the topic that I love a lot.
It's Azerbaijani cuisine.
So thank you very much.
And before I begin my
presentation, I'd like to mention,
we have stickers under four chairs.
So four of you will win my cookbook,
and I will happy to
sign them for you.
So do we do it at the very end?
Because everybody is
reaching for the stickers.
So four people, lucky
people, and I'll sign it
for you after my presentation.
Okay, well, they're
looking for that thing.
Okay, in 2007, when I had just
started researching Azerbaijani
cuisine for my book, I stumbled
upon this beautiful quote
by Anya von Bremzen.
She's a prominent food writer.
And I saw this quote in
her famous book Russia,
Please to The Table the quote read,
"Azerbaijani cuisine is perhaps the
most distinct, yet the least known
of all three Caucasian republics."
So this idea really stuck with me,
and I carried it the seven
years of my work on the book.
I thought I really wanted to deliver
the beauty Azerbaijani cuisine,
the diversity of it, how it
steeply seeped in the culture
of people populating this
territory and the history
of people, living on that land.
So I hope I achieved my
goal, and after seven years
of working, the book was published.
So what is Azerbaijani cuisine
and why is it so distinct?
What makes it different
from other cuisines
or what makes it common
with other cuisines?
My lecture will give you a very
brief overview of the country.
Most of you are probably
very familiar with it.
I'll be very brief, and then
I'll talk about the cuisine,
the techniques of cooking
general ingredients
that we use in the cooking.
Then I'll talk about the evolution
of Azerbaijani cuisine
throughout the centuries.
And then we'll talk about
special days and food traditions.
This is Azerbaijan on a big map.
So you can see it's
a very small country
on the crossroads of
Asia and Europe.
It's bounded by the Caspian
Sea where the capital
of Buka is located, our
neighbors are Iran, Turkey,
Armenia, Georgia, and Turkey.
This is the map of Azerbaijan.
I don't want to talk too
much about the country,
because you probably already know.
I'll switch to the country
overview, to the cuisine overview.
So what are some of the main
factors Azerbaijani cooking,
one of them is seasonality factor?
We use fresh ingredients.
Summer greetings in the summer.
Winter ingredients, feeding for
the winter, in the wintertime.
Hearty meals in the winter, light
vegetarian meals in the summer.
So this is a very important
aspect of Azerbaijani cooking.
And also, it's very used
to use fresh ingredients.
We go to farmer's market very often.
You know, farmer's market
operate every day over there.
It's not like here.
I don't know how it is here,
but in LA, it's once a week.
So Azerbaijan, it's every day, and
everybody shops very frequently
for the ingredients to use the
cooking, because cooking is made
from scratch on a daily basis.
Then there is a concept of sweet
and sour and some of the dishes,
and this is something that
came to our cuisine from Persia
from the times Azerbaijan was
part of the Persian Empire.
We blend, we mix sweet with sour.
For example, some rice pilafs the
toppings for some rice pilafs,
they have apricots, but at the
same time the top you may have
sour plums.
So it's beautiful combination.
It's delicious, but it's
also for the purpose of --
to balance the richness
of the dishes,
especially if it's a meat dish.
And also, sour ingredients help
with the digestion of the food.
So there is a medicinal
property, as well.
There is also minimum waste.
The idea of minimum waste.
For example, when we
slaughter sheep,
we try to use as much
of it is possible.
We make kebabs.
Then with the innards, we make
something that's called jiz-biz.
It's really good, unless
you're a vegetarian.
Then you won't like it, but it's
really delicious, and then the feet
and head is simmered for a long time
until we obtain something
that's called khash.
It's very good for
hangovers, but not always.
I love it.
I don't have hangovers,
but I love it.
So and also, wastes
are also sometimes used
for their medicinal
properties, as well.
What else?
And traditional food
preservation is very important.
We do have a lot of jarring
during the summer months,
but we also have a very old
tradition of preserving food
when there were no
refrigeration possible.
For example, we make
govurma, which is lamb fried
in its own fat and
stored for winter.
Then it's used, scooped out with
its fat, and added to the dishes.
Then we have something that's
called ghage or gujarat.
It's basically large pieces
of meat salted and dried.
Then you can use the dishes, as
well, especially pasta dishes.
In the coastal regions,
they dry fish and use it
in the wintertime, as well.
Cooking on a saj is
a very important.
Saj is a very interesting utensil.
It's a pan.
I think we have a picture
of it in the later slides.
Basically, it's a dome-shaped
vessel where you bake
and cook at the same time.
On one side, you bake breads.
On the other side, you
cook savory dishes.
And I'll show you the
pictures after that.
Okay, so these are the pictures.
This is a pomegranate car, a truck.
They sell pomegranates
in the trunk of the car.
I snapped this picture last year in
Baku during the pomegranate season.
And there are lots of fresh
herbs and the bazaars.
And this is a dairy seller that
came to our neighborhood in Baku,
and I was typing with my family.
I just took a picture of her.
She was very happy to
be in the presentation.
So this is something is
very common there, as well.
People, you know, neighborhood
vendors,
they go to the neighborhoods
and sell something.
This is our vendor over there.
I talked about this,
and I forgot this slide.
So this is kufta.
On the right, you can see kufta.
It's a huge jumbo meatball with
sour plum inserted in the middle.
This gives it a nice, tart flavor.
Also takes away the richness of the
meat and helps with the digestion.
And the khash that I
talked a little earlier,
the feet and the tripe is on top.
And on the bottom, you see cheese
that stored in the sheepskin.
It's called matal pendir.
It's called cheese that
stored in the sheepskin.
It's called matal pendri.
It has a very distinct flavor.
So we don't waste any
part of the animal.
And I talked about this.
This is dried meat in the middle.
That's how it looks,
and dried yogurt.
There's also a tradition of drying
the yogurt for the winter months.
When the yogurt is drained
and there is no liquid,
they shape it into cones
or circles or rounds,
and they dry it under the sun.
And they use it in pasta dishes.
Cooking on a saj, in the middle,
you can see flatbread stuffed
with meat, fresh herbs.
On the right is saj-cooked
lamb with vegetables.
I took this picture in the
region of Gabala in Azerbaijan.
It's a beautiful region,
and on the left,
you see this is an Azerbaijan crepe.
It symbolizes the sun.
When you pour the batter in
the middle, it spreads around
and you can see that it
looks likes the sun rays.
Breadmaking is very
important, as well.
Bread is a very important
aspect of Azerbaijani cuisine.
It's revered.
It's sacred.
It's been prepared and
Azerbaijan for centuries,
according to archaeological
discoveries.
And archaic methods
that were used back
in the time were really archaic.
Pieces of dough were
basically baked in the ground.
A hole was made in the ground.
Fire would start there,
then when members were hot,
a piece of dough would be
just put on top of embers
and the dough would be covered with
leaves, and the bread would bake.
But this is a very archaic method.
Later on, of course, with
time, other methods came.
You can see here a brick oven,
which is called kure, a big one.
In the middle, it's a tandoor oven.
It's very common in Azerbaijan, and
you basically, you slap the dough
against the wall of a heated
tandoor, and the dough doesn't fall.
It just stays there until
it's nice and golden.
And on the right, it's lavash.
Flat bread baked on the side.
When I was researching
for my cookbook,
I realized how diverse
Azerbaijani cuisine is.
My family is from different parts
of the country, from Ordubad,
from Balakan, from Zaqatala.
There really, I called a triangle.
One part is here, another
here, and I'm from Baku.
So the cuisines of all of these
regions are very different,
and as I researched for the book,
I realized how diverse it is.
Not only within the regions,
but also there are many cuisines
of ethnic minorities, the
population of Azerbaijan.
For example, I found out
that Molokan Russians,
that came to Azerbaijan in the 19th
century when they were expelled
from Russia because of their
belief in spiritual Christianity,
they settled in Azerbaijan.
And there is a village Ivanovka
is populated by Molokan Russians,
and they preserve their
ways of cooking.
They make laksha, these
noodles, the old-fashioned way.
They make pierogi of
many kinds on Easter.
There's also the cuisine of
the mountain Jews that came
to Azerbaijan in the
5th century from Persia.
They have a very distinct
cuisine, as well, that is a mixture
of Persian cuisine,
Azerbaijani cuisine.
They have elements
of different cuisine.
So these are some examples
of the diversities.
We have many kinds of baklava.
The one in the picture
is guba-style baklava.
It's different from Baku style
because here the dough is made
with rice flour versus Baku style.
It's made with wheat flour.
And that's stuffed --
[ Inaudible Speech ]
Oh, you can't hear?
Can you hear well?
Can you hear?
Hello. True.
Hello? Can you hear?
>> Yeah.
>> Feride Buyuran:
Okay, much better?
Okay, sorry.
I'd like to talk about the
history of Azerbaijani cuisine.
One of the most important factors
that really started the development
of Azerbaijani cuisine is
the Silk Road that started
in China's Xinjiang
Province in 183 BC,
and it lasted to the 15th century.
So all these caravans
started bringing spices, rice,
and all kinds of commodities,
passed through Azerbaijan,
and there are lots
of caravan routes.
You can see in the picture they're
basically inns that were built
to accommodate the traders
that passed through Azerbaijan.
This one is in Sheki,
and on the first floor,
the trade was happening.
The camels were resting.
On the second floor,
they were sleeping.
It's like a hotel room, and so with
the Silk Road, new ingredients came.
For example, spices came from India
we use a lot of cardamom and baking,
for Nowruz baking especially.
Cardamom, turmeric,
those fennel seeds,
anise seeds, they came from India.
And saffron came from Persia.
So the silk Road really played
a big role in bringing a lot
of ingredients to Azerbaijan,
and saffron was very important.
Still is. It came -- the
earliest mention of saffron
and Azerbaijan was
in the 9th century.
It was really expensive.
It was exchanged for
gold coins only.
And not all the ingredients came,
but also dishes came
with the Silk Road.
For example, we have this dish
which is like a rice pudding.
It's called firni.
The same thing is made in Iran.
A very similar dishes made in
Pakistan in northern India.
So it's believed that it
came with the Silk Road,
and very good firni
is made in Sheki.
My assumption is that it came
to Sheki first via the Silk Road
and then it distributed to
the rest of the country.
But I haven't proven it yet.
It just my assumption.
Tea becomes a staple, as well.
Azerbaijan is a very
big tea drinking --
we have a very big
tea-drinking culture.
There's a kettle on the stove
all day long, and whoever walks
in the door, we have to
treat them to a glass of tea.
But how did tea come to us?
It came from China via
the Silk Road, again.
The leaves originated in China,
but until the 18th century,
it was mostly an import.
So we really didn't
grow tea ourselves.
It was mostly coming from
other places from China,
but in the 19th century
-- in the 18th century,
the first factory was established
in the church of Azerbaijan,
and that's how the tea industry
developed in the country.
And this is a glass of tea.
You can see this is samovar,
something that came from Russia,
More of our Russian influence,
although a very archaic,
samovar was found on the
church of Azerbaijan in Sheki.
So there are theories about
where samovar was first born,
but the shape resembles
the Russian style,
and the glass is a
pear-shaped, just like in Turkey.
We call it [non-English
word spoken],
which comes from [non-English
word spoken] is pear.
So it's pear-shaped.
And what else?
So in the 7th century, Arab
expansion happened in Azerbaijan.
With that changes happen, as well.
For example, sharbat a
more commonly used drink,
versus wine that was were popular
before that, because the consumption
of alcohol was prohibited in Islam.
And you can see beautiful vessels
here in the middle and on the right.
This is where sharbats were served.
In the middle, this is called
[non-English word spoken],
and on the right, later on, after
the 15th century, it was replaced
with special bowls,
intricately ornated and designed.
And Turkic migration
was also brought a lot
of changes to the cuisine.
Turks it started to populate
the territory of Azerbaijan
from the 6th to the 11th century.
More Turks came in the 11th
century, and with them,
they brought their own cooking
techniques, their own ingredients.
They brought this art of making
kebabs, very down to earth dish,
but it was very popular
in Azerbaijan.
They also brought dumplings, which
are believed to have traveled
through Central Asia from China,
and we have a lot of dumplings.
You can see the picture
in the middle.
These dumplings are called guza
and they resemble Chinese
[non-English word spoken]
or Japanese[non-English
word spoken].
And Azerbaijan gurza.
I think the name is
very similar, although,
guza also is the name of a snake.
So also, you see arishta, which
is believed to have traveled
from Persia, although it's believed
that the Turks really embraced
it and made it their own.
We use noodles.
Those are noodles, basically.
And there is also, we were also
introduced to the use of yogurt,
which is a staple in
Azerbaijani cuisine.
We scoop yogurt on
top of many dishes,
vegetarian dishes, pasta dishes.
You can see in the picture
soup that's called dovgha.
It's a yogurt soup filled
with lots of fresh herbs.
It's very refreshing and
delicious at the same time.
The most dramatic impact of --
on Azerbaijani cuisine happen
during the Soviet Union.
What happened during the
Soviet Union, you know,
the Soviets had this
idea of the same for all.
So that means that all the republics
that were in the Soviet Union,
part of the Soviet Union,
15 republics altogether,
they had to have the same
eating habits, the same menus,
so they introduced the
same for all style.
Cafeterias opened across
the country,
and all of these cafeterias
served the Soviet-style foods,
which include some
of the things you see
in the picture [non-English
word spoken], for example.
These sausages, Soviet-style
sausages.
There was mashed potatoes;
[non-English word spoken],
which is meat patties.
Buckwheat and other
similar Russian foods.
So everything was controlled
from Moscow.
That's where all the rules were
made, all the decrees were adopted.
And the cuisine was primarily based
on elements of Russian cuisine,
although for festive occasions, they
adopted elements of other cuisines.
For example [non-English
word spoken],
which comes from the word
[non-English word spoken].
It's a kebab.
They adopted it from the Caucuses
and also from Central Asia,
but mostly it was built on the
elements of Russian cuisine.
Some not very good things
happened during the Soviet time.
Rice production declined.
When I was researching for my book,
I realized that before the Russians,
before the Soviet Union was
established in Azerbaijan,
there was a big rice-growing
industry in the country.
When the Russians came,
when the Soviets came,
they realized that this is a very
labor's process to grow rice,
and it wasn't really fitting
the Soviet style of eating.
So a lot of plantations, rice
plantations, were abolished,
and instead of them, cabbage
plantations were started,
potato plantations started.
So rice dishes that
were very popular before
and were really a part of the
cuisine before, now they became,
they started to be served
at the end of the dinner
for something, or something festive.
Spice bazaars also were demolished,
because Soviet cuisine did not
require the use of a lot of spices.
So spice bazaars disappeared,
as well.
And new drinks came into existence,
such as European-style drinks.
Sharbats disappeared, and the
German winemaking tradition
that existed before the Soviets
came also suffered, as well.
We had a German population
Azerbaijan that came.
Those were German colonies that were
established in the 19th century,
and they brought with them
their winemaking skills,
and they started winemaking
industry in Azerbaijan.
Unfortunately, they had to be
exiled to Siberia and Kazakhstan
because of the war of
the USSR and Germany.
In 1941, they had to
leave Azerbaijan,
and these are some pictures
of the German winemaking time,
and new breads were introduced.
Instead of traditional breads, such
as lavash, tandoor, and others,
Soviet style loaves, long and round,
were established across the country,
and my grandfather actually
owned one Soviet bakery.
That's his picture.
This is a picture of him.
He ran away from the
Stalinist exile.
He hid in another region, and later
on, he realized there was a need
for a Soviet-style
bakery, and he started one.
So that's him down there.
And after the collapse
of the Soviet Union,
goods things started to happen.
We started to receive a lot of
new foods from other countries.
The first foods that came to us
in Azerbaijan were Turkish foods,
because of the proximity
of the regions,
and also because of the
tastes were very similar.
So the first foods that came
to Azerbaijan, I remember,
in the early 1990s, when the
Soviet Union had just collapsed,
was the doughnut kebab,
the spiraling meat
that was really fancy back then,
but it's really widely spread now.
So Azerbaijanis started to
reclaim their traditions
of preparing traditional meals
more often now in restaurants,
they serve a lot of things
that were not served before,
for example, piti.
This is piti.
It's a lamb stew with chestnuts
cooked in a special pot.
And special days in food traditions,
you've heard about
Nowruz a little bit.
So I just want to say that a lot
of traditions, a lot of holidays,
they have food traditions
involved in them.
So in weddings, a lot of foods,
even when two families meet,
the families of the bride and groom,
the first ceremony, when they agreed
to the marriage, is a tea ceremony.
They sweeten the tea, which
means that the union is going
to take place, and so the
commemorations, for example,
when death happens in the
family, halwa is made.
It's believed to soothe
the pain of the grief,
and this is my daughter holding a
plate [non-English word spoken].
It's sprouted wheat.
They symbolize abundance
and fertility,
and this is Baku-style baklava,
one of many styles of baklava
that is made in Azerbaijan.
You can see the different styles,
you can read about the different
types of baklava in my cookbook.
This is a Baku style or Ganga style
baklava, and this is shakerbura.
It's intricately designed
with something
that is called [non-English
word spoken],
and baklava actually
symbolizes stars.
Shakerbura symbolizes
half-moon, and this is shorgoghal.
It symbolizes the sun.
It's a flaky, spice-filled
flatbread.
They're really good.
And the most important thing is
the tradition of hospitality.
We have a saying that says,
"A house without a guest is
like a mill without water."
And it's very true.
For Westerners, our hospitality
may seem overwhelming,
because we push everybody
to eat and drink.
Even if you are not
hungry, you have to eat.
So you cannot refuse the food,
because you have to be polite,
because there is so much labor put
into preparing something for you.
Always express gratitude
to the host.
At the very end, I wanted to
review this quote that I found
in Alexander Dumas's book
Adventures in Caucasia.
I really love this.
It really gives the gist
Azerbaijani culture.
So this is what he said.
"The officer commanding the
nearby village of Sourakhani came
to invite us to take tea with him.
Tea is hardly the right word,
for we found he had prepared
an excellent supper for us,
a Tatar meal of shashlyk,
pears, grapes, and watermelons.
He also offered us rooms if
we cared to stay the night."
Tatar, by the way, is how we were
called during the Russian Empire,
and I hope you get to try the
signs of hospitality firsthand
if you visit Azerbaijan, and I hope
you try the food of Azerbaijan.
If you don't go there,
we have food served here,
courtesy of the Embassy
of Azerbaijan.
Please enjoy it, and
thank you very much
for listening and for coming here.
[ Applause ]
>> Joan Weeks: Just
for a few questions.
I think we have time
>> Feride Buyuran: Yes.
>> Joan Weeks: I think we
have time for a few questions
if anybody has a question
for our speaker.
Yes?
[ Inaudible Speech ]
Can you -- time.
>> Feride Buyuran: I missed
the first part of your --
[ Inaudible Speech ]
It's more nationwide.
For example, in Baku, there
are restaurants that serve food
from other regions of Azerbaijan,
something that, for example,
hasn't been served during the Soviet
times, but now it's being served.
So it's more on a general,
in general, yes.
>> Joan Weeks: Any
other questions for us?
Yes, Angela?
>> [inaudible] like there
is here in the US for meats
that are organic versus non-organic?
Are the animals that you have
there fed [inaudible] or --
>> Feride Buyuran: I think there is.
I haven't lived there for 15 years,
but I believe if you buy
something that's, for example,
my mom never buys chicken
that's sold in supermarkets.
She buys chicken from somebody
who raises the chickens herself.
Like it's village-grown chicken.
So naturally, it doesn't have
any hormones or everything,
but as far as I know, some
of the chickens that sell
in the supermarkets have some
bad stuff, just like here.
You know? So there is a
classification just like here.
>> Joan Weeks: One last question.
Anybody? Well, I think
we're all very anxious
to taste some of this cuisine.
If you search under your chair,
four people will find a red bow,
and if you have a red
bow, if you bring it up,
Feride will sign your book,
and the rest of us can go
start through the line.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.